a stunning shake-up in the world of golf
is getting a lot of criticism this
morning as the PGA Tour and European
tour plan to merge with the Breakaway
live golf tour backed by Saudi Arabia
yesterday's announcement was sudden and
it was unexpected critics calling it a
Saudi takeover of men's professional
golf Manuel Hawkes has more now from
Miami
this ultimately is a decision that I
think is in the best interest of all the
members of the PGA Tour it's a union
that seemed unimaginable but one PGA
Tour commissioner Jay Monahan is
doubling down on how did we go from you
know a a a confrontation to now being
partners
we just realized that we were better off
together
than we were fighting or apart
last year the Saudi Arabian government
launched live to rival the PGA Tour
offering hundreds of millions of dollars
to the world's top players notable
Champions splintered off leading to a
bitter divide I think that uh
what they've done is they've turned our
their back on what has allowed them to
get to this position the guys who stayed
loyal to the PGA Tour
um
uh
it's kind of kicking the teeth for them
players on tour reacted to Tuesday's
announcement swiftly and harshly one
calling the move hypocrisy some met with
the commissioner late Tuesday afternoon
I would describe the meeting as intense
uh certainly heated it's been a very
Dynamic and complex couple of years
since live golf's Inception last June
it's drawn accusations of being tied to
sports washing by the Saudi regime a
campaign of sponsoring sporting events
to divert attention from a long record
of Human Rights atrocities including the
2018 murder of journalist Jamal
khashoggi and the country's alleged ties
to the 9 11 terrorist attacks something
commissioner Monahan criticized last
year and I would ask you know any player
that has left or any player that would
ever consider leaving have you ever had
to apologize for being a member of the
PGA tour in a scathing statement 9 11
families United called the deal a
betrayal Tuesday writing PGA Tour
leaders should be ashamed it appears
their concern for our loved ones was
merely window dressing in their quest
for money circumstances change I
recognize that people are going to call
me a hypocrite and anytime I've said
anything I said it with the information
I had at that moment I don't think
there's any way around looking at the
fact that this is a win for the Saudi
Arabian government this Golf League
writer David dusek says live forced the
pga's hand so is the moral of the story
The Money wins it's certainly
unfortunately looks like in this case
then yes if you bring up a big enough
Brinks truck of money that eventually if
you just keep bringing the trucks of
money again and again and again you're
going to be able to find just about
everybody's prize
so what's next well Monahan says this is
a framework of a deal not a done deal
yet there are still things that have to
be hammered out what we do know is that
players who joined live golf and were
later suspended from PGA Tour events
will eventually be allowed to return and
that has angered some players who stuck
by the PGA Tour Tony
shock and anger Manny those seem to be
the two dominant emotions thank you very
much if I'm a player who said no to
hundreds of millions of dollars now
those groups have merged I am very hot
this morning just a description of the
meeting being very heated and very
intense something I always try to avoid
it's hard to understand if you've turned
down the money now that they've merged
together I I I it's hard to understand
this move and even when Jay Monahan says
I know some people may feel it's a
hypocritic we're better together apart
many people say how I think people want
more explanation don't you yeah I think
we have something coming up in the show